U.S stripped of AAA rating by Fitch as
budget deficits as well this is a
Bloomberg story Fitch ratings down
greater U.S debt from AAA to double A
Plus due to Consumers over swelling
budget deficits with the federal deficit
reaching a 1.39 trillion dollars for the
first nine months of the current fiscal
year up 170 percent from previous year
treasury secretary Janet Yellen called
the downgrade arbitrary and outdated but
Fitch Justified the move citing
potential deterioration in the country's
finances over the next three years due
to tax cuts now spending initiatives
economic shocks and political gridlock
despite the downgrade the bond market
remained relatively stable but risk
sensitive assets took ahead with Europe
stock 600 index tumbling the most in a
month the downgrade underscores the
worsening U.S fiscal Outlook with Fitch
forecasting the debt to GDP ratio
to rise to 118 by 2025 more than two and
a half times higher than AAA median of
39.3 percent Graham when you see this
you're in the real estate space some
guys are saying it's not a big deal
you're overreacting stop this isn't
anything it's just this it's just that
you know and then there's some that's
saying this is pretty bad I mean you
know Kevin O'Leary came out said this is
not anything that's regular this is very
bad on what's going on here yeah where
do you stand with this I think a default
should never even be in the conversation
the fact that we even had headlines that
say oh the U.S risks a default it should
never even be a consideration the fact
that it is and it's being used as a
leverage point I think is awful totally
it shouldn't be used as that there
should be no question whatsoever that
the U.S is going to pay its debts on
time as agreed always so the fact that
this is being used is a possible
scenario in the past for negotiation I
think is awful but I mean they're not
exactly wrong with what they're saying
so I do I think in the long term is this
gonna matter probably not but I do think
all the concerns that they bring up are
I don't see any issue with them I mean
they're not wrong yeah I I totally agree
with you um and I think this is serious
and I actually
um disagree that this is not serious and
and you didn't you know the second part
of of of the of the of the you would say
in Spanish La noticia of the information
is the same week
that the federal government was
negotiating the debt ceiling increase
same week
Miami got a credit rating increase to
its highest level ever s p so you can
Google that Miami s p rating same exact
week
um so
running for president because we you
know I'm you know I'm here to talk about
Miami and what I did in Miami but I also
want to translate into how it makes me a
good presidential candidate I'm the only
candidate period that has cut a public
sector budget
full stop 20 the Delta between our
income and our expenses as a federal
budget is a 20 Gap right now
it's going to be ugly very ugly I've
done it it's going to be very ugly
number two I inherited a bankruptcy when
I got you know people look at Miami oh
14 growth this is great you know
whatever blah blah I inherited a
bankrupt City My City on day one 2009
when I got elected I was the only public
official that didn't get elected with
Union support because I wouldn't lie to
my employees I told them we're gonna
have to cut costs and it's going to come
out of you we're not going to raise
taxes and that's exactly what we did
okay we had to balance a 600 million
dollar budget
uh to 450 approximately 115 million
dollars we had to cut from our budget
115 one year by the way we didn't get a
four-year phase in a five-year phase in
nothing we now have the highest uh
reserves ever
highest we're going to have a super high
individual year Surplus and the highest
Bond rating ever we were fiscally
um sound we tightened our belt we did
things that government doesn't do which
is be disciplined and do what every
American does though every American
bounces a checkbook hopefully right and
and so what we should be promoting in
our country right savings like you said
and so I think this is a big issue to
your point they've postponed it till
after the presidential election which I
thought was
um you know I don't think that's a good
you know that's a good idea I think it's
wrong because so the next president is
going to have to walk right into that by
the way when I first got elected mayor
so I've confronted this deficit in 09 as
commissioner and then I had to
reconfront it as mayor because we got
sued by our labor partners 13 lawsuits
we won 12 out of 13. the 13th we lost at
the Florida Supreme Court okay it was a
700 million dollar liability on a fifth
on a on a in our budget
and I said to the guys I said look I
didn't lie to you in 2009 when I told
you we were not going to be able to
raise taxes and we're not going to be
able to increase your your compensation
we have to cut your compensation we did
tiered salary Cuts pension Cuts Etc
never done before in the history of
Miami
I'm not gonna lie to you now if you
bankrupt the city of Miami when we just
grew 10 and a half percent everything is
gone all your cookies all the stuff it's
all gone and they believe me and they
listen to me and so I negotiated that
debt down
for I think it was 18 cents on the
dollar from 700 million to 50 million
we'd even pay it all up front we paid
like 20 million up front and 10 million
over three years
um and so look it you have to that's
where the private sector public sector
experience is important let me ask any
word on Fitch and then I'm going to come
to you and then and then go ahead you
know first of all it's it's not what
happens to our bonds because Jamie
Diamond and Janet Yellen are saying two
slightly different things but they can
both be right Jamie dimon says it
doesn't really affect the US government
debt because the price is determined by
the market and people are still going to
be buying billions and billions of
dollars of government debt of the
countries like Japan and China that
speculate and Hold Us government debt so
that's going to change much what does
change is the waterfall effect and the
capital markets across the globe because
you saw what happened the European bond
market dropped so there was real loss of
value on one day in the European bond
market because Fitch drops on U.S and
although we've had headlines about
defaults have we ever defaulted you know
the debt ceiling is just the next
version of a Marvel movie and it's kind
of pathetic you know the world's going
to get saved you just look at your watch
and say it's going to be at about 2
hours and 15 minutes into the movie and
I think it's pathetic because I disagree
a little bit with you on that it kicks
the can down the road every time we
raise the debt ceiling here you I have
to disagree a little bit with you on
that because I think what happens and
you see this in in the history of
conflict right to your point this debt
ceiling debate or whatever you want to
call it right
um it's it's a it's a standoff right a
Mexican standoff or uh you know
um and what's going to happen is which
is what happens when there's nuclear war
right is sometimes neither side
flinches
right both sides dig in for whatever
reason whatever their reasons are and I
think to your point not solving a
problem continue to Kick the Can down
six months a year year and a half there
will be a moment where both sides will
dig in
thinking that the consequences will not
be as bad as as what they will be it
will happen and I think the I believe
personally and of course this is it's
like saying what is Putin going to do
next I mean who knows right who can get
into his mind
um I believe that the consequences will
be dramatic and dire that's what I
believe maybe it will never happen
because of that reason right maybe
hopefully or maybe a president like me
gets elected and decides we got to
balance our budget like this has to be
the number one priority because by the
way we haven't even talked about
inflation and interest rates or what I
call bidenomics the poor get poor right
in bionomics right uh through increased
through increased in inflation and
interest rates most people have their
money in bank accounts so they lose
purchasing power they want to buy a
house they gotta they gotta pay more
interest so they get squeezed on both
ends but if that doesn't happen if we
don't by the way we're living on
fictitious money
fictitious money I agree 20 right it's a
huge huge Delta I mean this is a huge
huge Delta so so to bring that back into
line it's going to take discipline it's
going to take pain and it's going to
take a good tax policy that will grow us
out of it at some level but it's going
to take reducing expenses which we
hopefully are prepared to do mayor
Source I have a
sort of a policy and personality
um question for you right so
um you talked about the project possible
yeah right so there's maybe there's
people that's listening that are like
hey I like this guy yeah super like old
guy but he's he's in Miami it's Miami
I'm in Iowa I'm in New Hampshire I'm in
South Carolina what is he going to do
for me right so
um number one how can you take the you
know the Miami model and and extrapolate
that for being the nationally and then
you know like we highlighted before
politics is so diverse right now but I
mean I don't know if the camera can
consensus you're a super likable thank
you aspirational positive optimistic guy
that's sort of your message for America
you know from a from a policy
perspective debt GDP like Graham was
talking about inflation but also just
getting along being a synergist coming
to to Washington how can you take what
you've done to Miami the Miami model
economically but also personality wise
what could you bring to DC well I think
I can I hope I can convey the
personality that I have the right
personality that I'm a consensus Builder
that I'm a unifier and that's based on
my record as getting like to buy 85
re-elected by 80 and changing a county
that was plus 30 for Democrats into one
that's plus 10 for Republicans based on
our policies but in addition to that the
biggest problems that we confront as a
nation
have to be confronted by someone who has
experience confronting them right and so
I would say the first problem is our
deficit and Rapid inflation and Rising
interest rates we've got to get control
that I'm the only candidate you can look
it up you can do the research that has
actually cut a public sector budget by
the same percentage that we have to cut
our federal budget the only one that has
that experience right so I have the
personality the skill set and the
experience to deal with that problem
problem number two immigration I don't
think that there is a better person
capable of dealing with immigration
which is a multi-faceted complex problem
than a Hispanic Republican president why
because you got to control the Border
you've got to
um I think depowering China is a big
part of dealing with immigration and
it's we can get into that if you want
but it's a complex uh sort of analysis
uh you've got to deal with you've got a
right-size legal immigration and I think
that has not been pegged to objective
metrics like like growth like the need
for skilled and unskilled labor
um the declining birth rate Etc
immigration in terms of legal
immigration should be pegged to those
factors and should float with those
factors right so that we may need 2x 3x
the number of legal immigrants I don't
know what that right number is but there
has to be a formula to solve it for
America's benefit right and I think then
you got to deal with the undocumented
and I think our Hispanic Republican can
help demystify
um that problem as you were saying but
you do this a lot in in Rogan's and and
you've done some of it today you know at
some level as as partisan politicians
were always counting votes right is this
going to benefit me as a party is it
going to hurt me as a party I'm not
likely to support a policy that may hurt
me as a party as I am likely to support
a policy that may benefit me as a policy
as a party and I think being a Hispanic
Republican president you are in effect
telling the Republican Party hey having
immigrants is a positive thing for this
country and
um if they're Hispanic this could
benefit the Republican party as opposed
to be a detriment you talked about some
of the polling numbers right we can
shift that and change that Dynamic which
changes the argument in many ways so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here